hi drew congratulations on the new show
sweetie
oh thank you so much i have to tell you
i was watching the trailer for your new
film and as someone
who was lucky enough to be in that
wonderful
magical movie-making world for so long
right your film that you wrote and
produced this is
really from talk about from your heart
and your mind
this movie looks so big and polished and
epic it looks like under the tuscan sun
meets eat pray love it looks like a very
large budget big scale important movie
and
i got emotional watching it i'm i'm in
awe of this enterprise
you know thank you for that we all we
are none of us made any money on this
yet
we we all it's a passion project i i am
the biggest fan in the whole world of
craig ferguson
and he hosted the today show with me for
a week when hoda went on maternity leave
and it was the most explosive
uh week of television i had ever ever
done
and we went to lunch afterwards and he
says cathy you know
if we wait around for our agents to get
us a job on television we're going to
die
waiting so i said oh you're right so
let's write a movie together
and i said okay but but it's so based on
the relationship
between me and and craig in real life
this chemistry that we have that is
i mean it's literally combustible i
i am i'm such a bad girl when i'm around
him
well worst in me and i love it you know
what i mean
i do and i'm really and i adore him
if it's okay i'd love to take a cl uh
look at a clip right now
okay let's let's take a look howard can
we please go back to the end the midges
are killing me
you really have a hard time not talking
don't you yes when i'm getting eaten by
midges yes
i'm hungry it's all the menjis
how long are you gonna sit there while i
get eaten
up they're not even biting you no
they're biting me
i'm just not making up a big song and
dance about it
and hilarity ensues i cannot wait to see
it i think you're gonna really
listen you know what in this day and age
two those
big movies are not in the theaters right
now it's
like the avengers and the tentacles and
it's just a different time
and i feel like you're really serving
something up that is not there
for the taking and it doesn't look on
this level
this really looks like a time in
hollywood where they were
really putting it all up on that screen
and it's really exciting to see this
this one is a romantic comedy drew for
people who
no longer believe that that they'll ever
have romance again
and nothing's very funny anymore they've
had a lot of loss in their lives you
know
but there are millions of people out
there like that and hollywood you know
better than anyone
doesn't really make a lot of movies for
people like that
annabelle has spent her whole life
married to the same man
uh owning a hardware store in nantucket
never seen the world except through
movies
and um all of a sudden her her life is
shattered
uh when her husband dies unexpectedly
so i think this movie is going to give
people hope i hope so it's uh
the line that's getting a lot of
attention from it is um
when she's saying to her husband's ashes
i love you fred
but i got to make new memories or the
old ones are gonna kill me
and i'm not i'm not ready to die not yet
i mean when you said like
you don't know if you're gonna find love
again that just really hit me i mean
oh yeah there's hope though you know um
there's a one of the songs that bretton
i wrote called once again and it says
you don't you don't find love love finds
you
in the midst of a moment right out of
the blue it sneaks up on your heart
hardly making a sound
till all of a sudden you find you've
been found
and that's what real love is you know i
i it just all of a sudden you kind of go
oh my god
my life just changed my heart just
changed everything's changed
yeah and i'd love to have it again in my
life i don't know that i ever will
i had a great love two beautiful kids
um almost 30 years with my best friend
and my lover and my
my my my hero until he broke my heart
and then we had to
start building all over again but that's
life that's real love
you know it's the test of time kind of
love and i'm running out of time
tick-tock mama's mama's running out of
time
i will tell you that there in this movie
i think you are really
taking uh the baton and the relay race
for all of us
and the themes of will we find love
again
how do we live out the rest of our lives
our fantasies
in fact there's a real life fact i
wanted to ask you about because it spoke
so much to me
that apparently there were times where
you would land
you know in new york um and you would
feel like
is this where i'm supposed to be having
nothing to do with the state
but you know you had fantasies
of another life in another place
and you realized them i'd get on a plane
in nashville on my way back home because
to be back on the
the today show the next day and i go why
am i
so happy when i'm down here what is this
because i thought that when i left the
today show i was going to move to
to california i said i'm going to die in
santa barbara it's such a beautiful
place
it's a great place to die and live is to
die
and and but but spending a year here
with the it's it's a culture of kindness
here drew people are
they don't care who you're going to vote
for they don't yell at you
they don't try to tell you how to think
or how to how to worship
they let you be as a human being i found
a real faith-based community here
god bless you kathy lee i was praying
for you this morning i've never met them
before
and and i believe them they were praying
for me that morning
you know it's just sweet it's like sweet
tea down here
i love it and you deserve to be happy
and exactly where
you want to be and again that's why i
think everybody's on this journey with
you is because we all are trying to find
our happy place and where we're supposed
to be and realize all those dreams
and you're going for yours and you're
doing it in ways that we can all
escape with you on them